Nebulas to nebulas, dust to dust.
What happens when a galaxy goes bust?
Hello aspiring galactic overlords and their
bumbling henchmen, Trace here.
This is DNews.
Galaxies are collections of millions and billions
of stars, the Milky Way probably has 100 to
400 billion or so (we don’t really know).
Andromeda, our closest neighbor galaxy, probably
has 400 billion stars (but could have a trillion!).
The thing is, Andromeda is likely dead.
Probably has been for a few billion years.
Just like stars, planets, you, me, and our
hopes and dreams -- galaxies can die, or ‘quench’
as astronomers call it.
In fact, half the galaxies in the universe
are dead, and thanks to a recent study, we
are starting to figure out exactly how they
died.
Gasses like hydrogen are used by galaxies
to make new stars; as the gasses fuse, the
hydrogen is fused into helium, and then the
helium into more elements like carbon, oxygen,
iron, and so on.
As long as stars are being created, a galaxy
is deemed “alive,” but when galaxies stop
making new stars… they’re considered “dead.”
The Sloan Digital Sky Survey (which has been
routinely observing the sky since 2000) has
found nearly 50 million galaxies so far, and
through all this data scientists recently
found one way galaxies can die…
Galaxy Strangulation.
Basically, the hydrogen gas that the galaxy
needs to make stars is slowly cut off, and,
four billion years later, according to this
recent paper in Nature, GALACTIC DEATH.
There are a number of things that can strangle
galaxies.
If the victim galaxy ventures near a massive
body like a black hole, another galaxy, or
galactic cluster, gravity can pulls gas from
the interloper, suppressing star formation
-- and starting it on a path to death.
This is called Galaxy Harassment.
Or, if that weren’t bad enough, there’s
Ram Pressure Stripping, when victim galaxy
gets too close to a hot x-ray-emitting cluster,
and the “wind” from the hot cluster “blows”
the star-forming gas out of the victim!
Space is pretty insane.
They finally figured out galactic strangulation
by looking at all those metals the galaxies
make while alive, and determined: that by
looking at the shape and color of a galaxy
you can see it’s life cycle, and how it
died.
Galaxies have color and shape, collectively
called morphology.
They can be lots of shapes, but their colors
are a bit simpler to grasp.
New, young stars make galaxies blue; they’re
burning their fuel fast and loose, being reckless
and staying out late.
Inside those galaxies are patches of red and
pink -- called HII (H-two) regions.
These are the star-forming regions, and they’re
mostly visible in ultraviolet (which is one
of many reasons why we need lots of telescopes
to see all the things going on in the night
sky).
As they age, galaxies lose the HII regions,
the young stars within them swell and cool…
and the galaxy turns red...
damn, too real.
As they get old, they tend to collapse onto
themselves forming elliptical little sad reddish
blobs.
On the shift from young blue galaxies to old
red ones, they are thought to move through
what astronomers call the “green valley,”
-- a joke about the color of light in-between
blue and red.
Without new stars coming up, the amount of
metal we can see increases.
Supernovas fuse more heavy elements, and the
now-dead galaxy cools and cools… eventually
become an infrared corpse galaxy.
InfraRIP.
So, I hate to be the one to tell you this,
but the Milky Way?
We just might be in the green valley.
We’re still making stars, but according
to a 2011 paper in the Astrophysical Journal,
we’re definitely in the mid-life stretch.
Don’t worry, y’all.
For now, our good old Milky Way is just fine.
For now...
If astronomers are right, we’ve got billions
of years of galactic life left.
And just because it’s not forming new stars,
doesn’t mean a galaxy is entirely dead.
There’s still a chance it can save itself.
Sometimes, “dead” galaxies, become zombie
galaxies…
Like our friend Andromeda.
Andromeda is dead, but still on the move,
and it’s heading this way.
Andromeda should collide with the Milky Way
in about 4 billion years, forming a new, massive
galaxy!
(FYI: our solar system will see this happen.
Our sun will have expanded and roasted earth,
but it will still be here.)
In true Báthorian fashion, old galaxies can
sometimes consume younger, star-forming galaxies
to extend their lives!
Maybe the merged Andromedy will be able to
reinvigorate its formation furnaces, and kick
some more life out of our galactic tires...
Even if we don’t, we’ll eventually merge
with more and more galaxies forming a massive
elliptical galaxy, filled with metal, and
burning near infrared.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
We talked a lot about colors and ages of galaxies
but what about their shapes?
How do they get those shapes?
Find out in this video.
Let us know down in the comments if you have
any other science questions you want us to
answer and subscribe so you get more DNews.